sinister middle eastern theocracies used
to spend
an awful lot of money with the clinton
foundation not to buy access we were
told
but to solve the world's big problems
like
obesity in the third world in hiv in
africa
from 2014 to 2016 contributions to the
foundation totaled over 130 million
dollars per
year and then something weird happened
particularly for such an effective ngo
like the clinton foundation
people stopped giving money and they
stopped giving right around the time
that hillary clinton's political career
hit a brick wall at high speed when she
lost the presidential election
in 2017 contributions the clinton
foundation went down
to 22 million from 2018 to 2019
contributions were even lower so what
happened did they
cure obesity in the third world is there
no more aids in uganda
what the hell is going on miranda devine
is a columnist with the new york post
and one of the smartest people we know
she joins us to explain so miranda
i i have sort of been contented
and reassured by the fact that as i
sleep chelsea clinton is working to cure
obesity
in the third world but it sounds like
they don't have any money to do it what
happened
well it is rather remarkable isn't it
says it all that their
their denotions just fell off a cliff
after hillary clinton lost that election
but look they've still been ticking
along they've just marked their
20th anniversary tucker so i think that
the foundation has found a new
uh way of doing things and that is to be
a vehicle
for chelsea clinton for any future
political ambitions she might have
so she's been busy saving elephants and
teaching children she got lady gaga to
help
tell children that they must wear masks
they've also been busy telling
the third world poor countries that they
should be taking chinese vaccines
they're helping them
in that aim lucky them and bill clinton
has also popped in from time to time
he appeared at a clinton foundation
junket the other day with kamela harris
and the topic was
empowering women so he's come a long way
and so the clinton foundation
is working hard considering their
straightened circumstances but you just
don't hear much about it
which might change because remember john
durham and the durham report well um
when he does eventually deliver his
report there might be something
interesting about the clinton foundation
because if you remember last year
he widened his investigation to include
the
fbi inquiry into the clinton foundation
which
curiously found nothing untoward but
maybe
john durham's found something else so
the clinton foundation may hit the front
pages
yet oh really quick i haven't seen the
public opinion polling
is there a hidden groundswell of support
among americans for
the reign of chelsea clinton at some
point in the future do you know
well look i don't know that um that
there is at the moment but then she's
just doing some background work she's i
guess you'd call it
um the groundwork because she's
polishing up her
reputation she's got a a very pricey job
at some corporate that she's doing and
she's had a makeover so
i think you know it's early days but
give her a few years
like 50. uh miranda devine great to see
you tonight thank you so much
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else